alright guys bang bang got the one and
only mr. Cuban here thanks for taking
the time to do this yeah it's mark I
hate that Mister stuff alright I started
off every interview with a billionaire
same question when did you realize you
had a billion dollars and what was that
like oh my god I was naked
literally the broadcast Comstock was
just going nuts and I knew obviously how
much how many shares I had so it was
back in the day on my PC and I was
sitting there hit f5 refresh and then
when I hit that number I just did my
little naked dance and you know went
back to work so LLL never forget it but
listen I know that's a real story
because most people won't admit stuff
like that but I said that's that's what
I would be doing us be refreshing the
[ __ ] out of it right so I did my little
naked dance and went back to work I love
it let's jump into other economic
situation maybe just give us kind of a
quick minute or two I'm just like where
are we right now and kind of how you
currently analyze the situation well you
know what we don't know right because
everybody sitting at home we're we're
we're in a situation out where we can't
look back right we can't look at America
14.0 we've just got to say okay what's
this going to be like when the doors
start to open up and we walk in walk out
the door into America 2.0 and what do we
want it to look like you know we've got
this amazing reset that's horrific in
some ways but it's an opportunity in
other ways and so we just have to ask
yourself businesses have to ask
themselves you know what am I going to
do when we're allowed to go back to work
employees have to ask themselves you
know what's it going to be like for me
and then we've got to figure it out so I
think a lot of changes are going to
happen I don't know exactly what it's
going to look like but I know there's
going to be an awful lot of opportunity
yeah and I guess one of the questions
that people really have said we've seen
the unemployment numbers we obviously
see how much demand there is for the PPP
loans and all that kind of stuff like
how bad is it for small businesses right
now right kind of like what's your
assessment of - it's not good cuz you
know when you start a company as an
entrepreneur it's always there's always
uncertainty right but you have a feel
for what the markets all about you know
your competitors are if there's any you
know what your product or service is you
know how to sell it that's why you
started the company you have a general
idea your prospects and your customers
are now that's all you know up in the
air nobody really knows and so you know
for most small businesses you're living
and a mouth right it's like okay no cuz
I'm never going through it I mean I
always tell the story we were about two
three years in and I had three employees
and I get a call from the bank and then
this guy was this Texas southern accent
go son we just had this lady come
through the drive-thru at the bank and
she had whited out the payees on your
cheque and rode in her name I'm like
tell me you didn't cash it right they
cashed it right so our back was against
the wall and that's the way it was when
we started that's the way most most
small businesses are so yeah it's gonna
be tough for small businesses but if you
can get through this knowing that some
of your competitors are gonna fall off
and if you if you can hustle if you can
grind you can you can make it into
something better but you gotta be agile
you gotta be resilient
you gotta recognize that things are
going to go wrong it's not going to be
easy but again agility smarts
aggressiveness hustle grind those are
going to be traits of small businesses
that do well yeah and it feels like
there's kind of two buckets right here
right there's people who are worried
about surviving through this and
obviously that into cash business there
and it's gonna dictate a lot of that and
then there's others that are kind of did
the hard work already they did the
discipline things and the good times
they've got strong balance sheets and
they're actually getting aggressive now
they're gonna go steal market share when
others are attracting yeah if you're in
a good spot right I mean there's some
companies that are doing well you know
some companies that are doing decent and
I'm telling you know those dive invested
in ramp it up right because the cost per
clicks the cost for customer acquisition
have gone way down you know YouTube
prices Facebook prices Google the you
know across the board twitter they've
all just dropped like a rock and so if
you can afford to go after and you have
a vision for what your company is gonna
be like right because you gotta know a
2.0 what your what what you're all about
where you're making your money and how
you're going to do it so if you have
that confidence to your product and your
service go go go go put the pedal to the
metal and don't stop to get we're
attitude yeah you keep mentioning kind
of America to point
maybe elaborate just like what exactly
does that look like in your mind is this
an acceleration of trends that were
already underway is there other things
that change what's difficult at the
things that caught people's attention
before are you know now are just right
in your face you know how do you treat
your employees what your brand
represents how do you treat your
customers you know how do your customers
brand themselves and how do you fit into
that so those are all elements of 2.0
but again if there's something that you
think could be better if there's a
better product if there's a better
service what is right you know I'm all
about robotics and precision medicine
and artificial intelligence you know
what is it that I can do there I'm about
you know when we create medicines in
this country you know we typically have
them manufactured overseas and there are
a lot of problems with them being
counterfeit not being as pure as they're
supposed to be and that created all
kinds of illnesses and challenges you
know so we had already started creating
some companies to address that you know
how can I accelerate those companies
like no duh AI or iolo that you know for
artificial intelligence the big
companies the fangs the googles the
Netflix the Amazons they already have
that cold right they're investing
billions thousands of AI engineers and
they're pushing that envelope all the
small to middle sized companies they
typically don't even understand AI and
so we're we're gonna walk into America
2.0 with a lot of haves and have-nots
the big companies are going to know how
to go to work and put their their
balance sheets to work the little
companies are going to have to try to
figure out how and where they fit with
AI and new technologies and so you know
if you've got a vision of how to put
these new tech technologies to work and
something you think should be just
radically different and you just got to
go for it and so I think there's gonna
be a lot of great companies created
what's it all gonna look like when it's
all said and done I don't know but
that's the opportunity right you know
that's why I'm trying to just visualize
where do I see it what do I think I need
to do how can I help how can I change
the game and you know then just be agile
yeah I think a lot of people are kind of
gravitated towards you on an unsharp
tape because you really hammer home like
this idea of the American spirit
and innovation that's like built what we
have today right it's built the greatest
country in the world it feels like in
times of crisis kind of the saying if
there's no capitalist in a crisis right
we get more towards the the other end of
the spectrum maybe talk a little bit
about like how do we ensure that we keep
true to the roots of innovation and not
ingenuity and entrepreneurship and kind
of use the American spirit to come out
of this that's who we are
right that's in our DNA that's what
makes us different than any other
country on the planet you know I mean
you don't see you know countries built
around entrepreneurship like you see in
the United States of America right they
don't talk about the French dream or the
Iranian dream right we talk about the
American dream and that's why you see so
many people come to this country even
when you look at some of the greatest
companies created over the last 20 years
they were started by immigrants who came
here knowing that this was the best
country in the world to start a business
that's not gonna change but you know you
have to pay attention to what's happened
you have to understand context you know
Bernie Sanders didn't have a movement
for no reason right there were a lot of
people who questioned capitalism there
are a lot of people who want stronger
rights for workers and deservedly so
there's a lot of people who rightfully
want a higher minimum wage you know
there's I went back for some of my for
my companies that that I run and ask the
question are any of my employees getting
government assistance because to me
that's the ultimate socialism when I'm
taking money when my employees are
taking money from the government because
I'm not paying them enough and so I
wanted to rectify that and so you know
for capitalism to continue to thrive
when we come out of this it's gonna have
to be a lot more compassionate you're
gonna have to put employees first you're
gonna have to put shareholders last you
know and that's gonna be good for
business because how you treat your
employees and customers is how your
brand is going to be defined forever you
know your people are not gonna want to
be associated with a company who just
who had money in the bank it just
ditched all their employees you know and
even if your backs against the wall and
your company was broke and you had to
lay or furlough or fire everybody
if you communicated with them and we're
honest and transparent then people will
understand that because you as an
entrepreneur or CEO you're getting
crushed just as bad you know and and so
everybody's in the same boat but you
know how you do
things now if you don't show compassion
if you're not nice if you're not
understanding if you don't offer equity
to employees as an example
you don't recognize you're gonna have to
pay people more to keep them um then
you're gonna be challenged yeah and we
see this before right I mean companies
that I've said strong cultures took care
of their employees they've always you
know tended to do well people really
write books about it because it's so
rare and now I think what you're
basically saying is hey everyone's gonna
have to start to put this as a core
tenet of without question I mean look
every single person who's on social
media which is pretty much everybody 40
and under right you know if not older
you know that's our brand what we put on
social media is who we are
and it's what we want everybody to see
about us and the products that we
discussed the products that we show on
our pictures you know the things that we
say and do those all represent who we
are and if you're not a product that has
a good culture that if you you don't you
know think of more than just the bottom
line people aren't going to connect you
people aren't gonna get behind you and
you're not gonna have a company you're
not gonna have a business you're gonna
be gone so the bigger picture is
capitalism has to be compassionate but
that's good business yeah for sure
obviously the economic crisis is
happening and we're getting a bunch of
monetary policy decisions that you know
some are good some are bad kind of
what's your general take on just what's
already been decided and kind of what
you think we need to do moving forward
monetary policy side you know I don't
want to throw people under the bus
because you know the reality is it's
easy because there are no great
decisions right now because we don't
have good information about anything you
know but there's a whole lot of things
that we're gonna have to redo we're
gonna have to redo healthcare and it's
not just about how we pay for it
it's about how we cost it you know I did
a lot with health care before all this
hit and if you look if you talk to
hospitals they don't know what their
costs are how much to fix that broken
arm from that kid in the ER they don't
know
you know how much for that hip
replacement they don't know but yet now
there's so much dislocation and
disruption because of it and they're
gonna need so much funding when we give
them that funding we're gonna have to
require some things back and part of
that's going to be you know you're not
bility you're not having the piano
player you're not having the artwork
right you're doing it so that when some
he needs to come in and get primary care
they can afford it because how you how
you invest in what you care you offer
defines how much you charge and so all
that's going to change you know how we
tax is going to have to change and it's
not just about taxing me more I'm fine
with that and always have been but you
know there's gonna be so much
forbearance of tax revenue there's gonna
be such a reduction in tax revenue we're
gonna have to give serious consideration
that things like a robotics tax you know
if you've got a job that could be done
by an individual and you're paying a
robot $25 an hour to weld then let's hit
that with the same twelve point four or
twelve point six I forget for the Social
Security tax you know and let's take
nine percent of that and put it into
Social Security in the Treasury fund and
let's put three point whatever percent
into investing into robotics research
for the country because we don't lead
the world in robotics whether it's
software or manufacturing of robots you
know we're behind Germany we're behind
Japan
we're behind China and the only way
we're gonna bring back jobs and the only
way we're gonna bring back manufacturing
from overseas no matter what country is
whether it's Asian Mexico whatever it is
it's through robotics we're gonna have
to out engineer we're gonna have to
out-innovate those manufacturing
alternatives that are less expensive
because of lower payrolls and and less
um climate restrictions and all those
things right we're gonna have to work on
robotics to bring all that manufacturing
back work on battery life work on manual
dexterity work on the software because
if we can do that and lead the world we
can get that manufacturing back it won't
be America of manufacturing 1.0 with
assembly lines and people sewing but all
the inherent jobs that come with
dominating worldwide manufacturing
whether it's support maintenance
monitoring you know software whatever it
may be the aggregate employment would be
much higher and the pay will be much
higher even for people with not defined
skills than it would be just trying to
recreate manufacturing 1.0 you know I
think we taxed cloud computing because
that's where AI resides and AI is not
going anywhere that it you know it's a
it's expensive for small companies to
use cloud computing right now
a different issue but for the
large-scale applications and processes
um I don't think we'll hurt any um any
advances by taxing cloud computing at
one or two percent so that's a long
answer but you asked yeah and I think
this really brings up and why we got
affected was you started really going
off on a bailouts right and I'm with you
kind of a hundred percent on this idea
of a lot of people I think are turning
to the government and they're saying hey
I couldn't go to the debt or equity
markets but I don't like the terms there
let me go find the idiot in the room
right oh the government will give me
better terms than my other investor will
give me so maybe help under like explain
what the issue with the bailouts are and
let's just stick with companies right
now and then we can get into like local
governments and all of that yeah so look
everybody's suffering at some level if
the company's been impacted dramatically
like we've seen Airlines like we've seen
the wedding industry like we've seen
cruise lines I'm not opposed to them
going to the government for help right
but when you give help when you and
effectively invest in a company whether
it's taxpayer money or my money or your
money you want something back it's never
a gift and so in this particular case I
think any company that of a specific
size like small company will set aside
as being a different example but for
larger companies then if we're investing
in them I want it to be an investment
not a gift and I want something in
return
we've seen what Warren Buffett has done
with Bank of America and Goldman Sachs
he gave them money
it was preferred stock plus he got
warrants he made a boatload of money
afterwards why can't the American
Treasury do the exact same thing the
American taxpayers deserve that and by
doing that we bring back the economy
much more quickly because you know yeah
it's it's expensive but to the people
getting that money but at the same time
I believe in this country and I believe
those stock prices are going to be much
higher at some point in the future just
like they were post the 2009 2010 Great
Recession and so it's a good investment
for the American people it's smart to
take that money for the companies
because you know they probably don't
have many alternatives and that's the
only way to do
I mean who else is going to give their
money and not ask for something back
yeah and I guess some of this too is one
just the the philosophy of doing it the
second is actual execution right now and
I love that you said hey look call your
senator off I'll come negotiate it with
it yeah absolutely
it is their merit to the idea of let's
go get five or ten business leaders who
have done these deals over and over and
over again and say look Treasury we're
gonna come in and you know you're not
gonna charge anything but we're gonna
help you negotiate fair deals or
advantageous deals or do you start to
get into a situation where it's just too
hard to do something like that I mean
everything's hard right now right so
there's going to be a challenge but you
know in reading as much as I could of
the law they they created an oversight
committee already right and so the goal
would be not to just have politicians on
that Oversight Committee right because
they're gonna be influenced they have
their own dogmas and they basically
represent two parties and so you want to
get some independent names on there
again I'll volunteer for the oversight
to they said all the contracts had to be
transparent and published right so
everybody's going to see them you know
and so you don't want to look stupid and
you don't want the entire country just
to think we just gave all this money
away our hard-earned taxpayer money
because somebody was just doing somebody
a favor or somebody didn't have the
skill set in order to do a negotiation
and so yeah I mean we want to have
transparency and it's okay on this
Oversight Committee to say to have
people in there who are gonna call them
out because the minute that first one
hits if it isn't well done rip them to
shreds right that's our job you know as
concerned citizens
why wouldn't we yeah you know if it's
not a deal we feel is a good deal for
the United States of America of course
you want to say something yeah and my
whole thing too is what why would you
not want to have people who have
experienced doing this stuff right
no-brainer you know what if the company
doesn't want bye-bye
go get your money somewhere else well if
the company is fighting back against
who's on the Oversight Committee that
probably means that they did a good job
selecting who's on the committee so
we've seen companies obviously go and
look for the bailout money now what
we're starting to see is yesterday we
saw a group of Governors come out and
say look we need five hundred billion
dollars to Bill
you see things like the MTA in New York
cities saying hey wait a second
ridership
down 90% we might not be able to pay our
bonds kind of you're getting outside of
just pure capitalism and private and
public companies into these other things
how do you think about bailouts or
relief or help for those types of
organizations I mean you have to do it
otherwise it creates a cascading effect
that could be far worse I mean look what
do they call it that mmt the monetary
yeah I forget what the acronym stands
for but where you just keep on you know
pretty money and then you see what
happens we're gonna find out right this
is a real-world experiment but you know
the other side of the coin is you know
what happens if you don't you know if
all these companies you know all these
organizations can't pay their bills you
know like the MTA you know like the you
know transportation organizations in
every city right the local governments
in every city are facing the same
problems if we don't pay it we know what
will happen so we've gotta try it so
yeah I'm not opposed to it but you got
to make sure there's no fluff in there
right and you've got to make sure that
it's being run as efficiently as
possible and I get look I'm a
libertarian it's at heart and the idea
of government being efficient is an
oxymoron but you know we don't have a
lot of options we just have to try to
have some good oversight yeah or you
didn't worry I generally agree that
they're gonna have to do it right
they're in a lose-lose situation they
got to do it do you get worried about
inflation on the other side of this
where it could get out of hand because
they've gloriam they're just printing
yeah but we thought about that before it
was just like okay you know when we do
all these bailouts in 2009 2010
inflation is gonna be rampant and it
wasn't you know and then we've had you
know other scenarios where the interest
rates go down to zero or negative
interest in other countries and
inflation hasn't been rampant it's been
you know deflation is born more of a
risk than inflation so you know every
economist will give you a different
answer I don't have an answer um but
we'll find out won't we and and we'll
know for the future because this is you
know a great experiment for future
generations now hopefully they're not
going to go through the same [ __ ] we're
going through but at the same time we'll
learn about monetary policy will learn
about fiscal policy will learn about the
impact of interest rates and we'll go
from there
yeah make sense one of the things that
I've been thinking a lot through is this
balance between the health crisis and
economic
crisis and I think a lot of people look
at it black and white they say hey there
you yeah stop the health crisis we
stopped that helmet crisis you just
can't make that decision and so how do
you think through on a framework basis
like you got to address both of them
it's like what are some of those
solutions that we can move towards what
kind of the way I'm looking at it I
actually see the health crisis is being
short-term right but the the economic
crisis is being potentially much
longer-term but you can't you you've got
to deal with both of them right and so
all the things we've been talking about
in terms of the economic issues yeah you
have to address that we're gonna have to
create jobs you know we're gonna have to
have tracers on that do you know higher
half a million a million people that
just go trace all these illnesses and
see where they trace back to if only to
create work right we're gonna have to do
things like AmeriCorps is a great
AmeriCorps is a great program that has a
small budget give them a huge or budget
because we're gonna have to create jobs
and that's gonna be a long-term issue
that we address hopefully like in
2009-2010 when we start to come out of
it relatively quickly and and you know a
couple years hopefully but on the health
side I'm really optimistic that we'll
have a vaccine you know in trial shortly
and out of trial within a year and we'll
have therapies within months but even
those therapies are going to take time
to build confidence and I just think you
know coming out of this people are going
to have to make the decisions make their
own decisions on what they do next
and that'll define where we go from here
and that's just going to take agility
you know and that you know that's going
to be the operative word for America 2.0
being resilient being able to bounce
back and be and hash out those two
things and you know but agility is gonna
be word number one yeah it's really
interesting too because I think that the
way we kind of went into quarantine and
lockdown really drove the point home
right as I hey get your asses at home
stay at home we gotta crush the curve
all the things that we saw on social
media et cetera the flip side of this is
now how do we come out of it right I
think that actually the way you come out
of the quarantine has a lot of impact on
the psychology do people go spend will
they go to that movie theater really do
this stuff any thoughts on just like yes
hug yeah the answer is No
right because it's going to be a process
there is no one thing there is no life
switch like everybody saying it will be
a process where you'll build trust and
you have to know that going into the
deals that you do so if part of a
bailout for an airline if the government
stands across all the airlines of
billion dollars a year for airline seats
for commercial travel
let's prepay that billion dollars and
let's work out a deal with Airlines to
say okay you know the first travelers on
your plane or your planes are going to
be government employees and here's the
requirements that we're gonna set in
place for your planes in terms of
sanitization sterilization whatever the
CDC etc requires and we'll do that and
you know we'll make sure that they're
okay and that'll start to build
confidence we'll work with sports teams
and arenas we'll put together programs
where we won't have an arena full but
we'll start playing the game so we can
leave see groups of people together in
an area that won't end up getting sick
again that goes back to the agility
we're gonna have to just test things out
and that's what'll build confidence and
of course there's gonna be kids that you
know feel they're invincible and they're
gonna go out and do whatever anyways so
gonna be back in the beach they're gonna
be back in the pools they're gonna be
back party and no matter what and then
we'll see an increased incidence in
infants on Kovac right and we'll learn
our lesson but it's going to be an
ongoing process but what I do think the
government needs to do is very clearly
set standards on cleanliness and
presentation right and information so
that if you're walking into if you're
going to the park and there's a park
bench and you want to bring your grandma
there you want to see a seal of approval
that says this is the last time this
bench was sanitized right it may be an
app where you just pointed out it may be
AR where it shows to whatever it may be
they're gonna have to be things that the
government sets the standards that our
confidence builders for us just like
when we went back after 9/11 and we had
the TSA there and the lines were long
and you knew was the pain in the ass and
you knew you could just run to the gate
anymore but that helped give us
confidence
we'll need the same type of standards
for from the CDC so that we ran whoever
maybe so that we know that the right
things are being done because we can see
the stickers everywhere
and when that starts to happen and
people don't get sick then you'll start
to see an acceleration of people coming
out and the new abnormal if you will
yeah it's like the confidence game of
the economic world is this gonna be the
same thing in the society as well part
of this I think is not only the facts or
the information but it's also the way
it's covered you know yesterday you you
had the tweet about the idea of all the
mainstream media kind of going away from
a presidential conference and obviously
super con controversial it's like what
was being said in all of that but just
on a more broad scale how do you think
that the media has been doing and
covering some of this stuff like what
are they doing well or where do you wish
they would improve I mean I not to look
at the tell TV news anymore or the cable
news because there's just all doom and
gloom great and I don't think that
really serves any purpose you know
particularly since the audience for
traditional television is older right
when you look at the average viewing age
for CNN and Fox and MSNBC it's 60 plus
right and so those are the people who
are terrified anyways because of all
this because they're saying element when
you look at the ratings and you know the
number of people 49 and under there are
25,000 of them watching any given any
given show so they're terrifying people
who are already terrified and so I think
that's a problem I think we need to
start talking more about what are you
gonna do on the other side right how are
you gonna bring back your business or
what are you as a consumer going to do
one of the things you're looking forward
to buying so that we have an indication
that you know what we will get through
this there is a better way to do things
and there's gonna be some exciting
things that we learn because all like we
talked about capitalism but there's
gonna be a lot of things that we
realized it wasn't right before let's
let's do a better way or there's gonna
be lots of young entrepreneurs that say
I got this right this is my vision they
may be a 12 year old or maybe there are
60 year old but there's gonna be new
visions let's talk to them and let's
scare some of those new visions and then
in terms of online it just kind of
replicates you know Twitter's Twitter
right everybody's going to go nuts on
Twitter but you know online new sources
are the same way here's what's wrong
here's what this person did wrong here's
what that person did wrong you never see
anything about what people did right
except for doctor Falchi right and dr.
Burks they're all heroes and that's
deservedly so
and the frontline health care workers
their heroes and deservedly so but let's
get some things positive and let's start
talking about America 2.0 they start
talking about how we get through it like
some of the things you and I are talking
about are more macro but there's going
to be a lot of things a lot of people
that have specific visions let's get
them out there and talking and getting
feedback you know cuz that's that could
be around the corner a month for now two
months from now you know we're not gonna
just do things all the same way let's
come up with a vision let's get fired up
right there's so I want to talk to those
entrepreneurs I want to hear about those
entrepreneurs I want to see what new
products or services I want to hear
about those visions because goddammit if
we went through all this [ __ ] I want it
to be for something right and that I
think that's what they miss if we went
through all of this let's make it for
something all those people who died all
those people who suffered let's make it
so that wasn't a bank let's turn this
into something that makes this country
better yeah it goes back to the whole
idea of the American spirit right you
keep talking about my kind of the
opportunity coming out of this it we
know that in Prior crisises there's been
great businesses that then built or kind
of early days in those crises what are
you seeing as those opportunities you
kind of machine healthcare or there are
other industries outside of healthcare
and AI that you think are gonna be big
or you all you see some of your teams
now saying hey look this is actually
where we think that vision is oh my god
so I had this guy company meepo and the
EPO who created new kinds of food so he
put and it took the nutrients of a
salmon dinner with sweet potatoes and
put it into a cube that they're
manufacturing right now they're at the
co-packer that's 340 calories and it
costs two bucks to make right so when
people are when we get caught with
shortages are people afraid to go out to
eat the you know or still if we get a
resurgence right and people clearly
older people can't get out of the house
or kids are not in school and can't get
fed you can get these things cheap and
they have more nutrients than trying to
eat you know a PowerBar type thing right
or a protein bar so you know that's one
example um how are we good you know how
are we gonna have fun you know so you
know right
here you can't see it I've got these two
bubble soccer balls right and so we're
talking about how can we bring all the
kids together if they bring their own
bubble soccer ball by definition you
know there's social distancing right and
they can just get out there and we
create our own little local instead of
you know the local baseball or football
or basketball league we're gonna play
bubble soccer you just get your own
bubble soccer ball just little I mean
it's silly in some respects but those
are types of things that accommodate the
new normal right that allow people to
try to get back to having some normalcy
and you know those are two areas that
just came out of left field right create
a team or do creative things yeah
there's so many more but that you talked
about the media let's hear about that
yeah right every every new show should
have at least one segment what about
this right America 2.0 what about that
right why not well and I think the data
suggests right there's watchin academic
studies one the positive news actually
goes more viral than the negative news
and then on top of that one of the
studies I saw was if you wake up in the
morning and read three positive
headlines you're more likely to say you
had a good day at the end than if you
woke up and read three negative
headlines so exactly we're not giving
anybody anything
you know yeah this is not about survival
I mean look we're gonna get through this
with this this is not a situation where
we're saying oh my god there's no
medicine coming we're arguing about
which medicine will work better
you know we're arguing about the best
way to deal with people are sick and
it's horrific you know that we can't get
it to everybody it's horrific that we
don't don't have the right solution for
every scenario yet but I think everybody
would agree that progress is being made
and that we're confident that we'll get
through it and because of that there can
be good news right and there can be a
vision for the other you know when we
get to the other side of this but we're
not hearing any of that at all except
from you of course yes no and I guess
part of the new normal as well is this
balance between more surveillance right
we saw in like the 911 situation where
we got the Patriot Act and TSA and all
this kind of stuff there's a lot of
people who are saying wait a second are
we gonna give up civil liberties
personal freedoms in exchange for more
safety how do you kind of think through
you know where's the line and kind of
how two citizens think through that
there's a guy named Scott
you started a company called Sun
Microsystems way back in the day it was
what's that
never heard of it with you and he says
you don't have any privacy no matter
what you walk down into the street in
New York there's a camera on you what
you like it or not right every every cat
every building has got a camera looking
out for it there's security cameras
everywhere you know we like having the
sense of privacy we really don't have it
but I think there's there's a limit to
how much people will give up but you
know we're going to have to give up
something just like we did with with
flight you know it would travel with the
TSA you know it's just it's just gonna
be a reality now hopefully we'll find
better solutions you know so that
they're not intrusive you know I don't
think temperature gauges are going to be
the thing right you know I don't think
just being tested you know is going to
be the thing but what we will have to
give up some privacy now where I do get
a concern is people getting labeled
right you have the antibodies you don't
right you've got it you don't have it
and because they'll start with this and
they'll extend to other areas and that's
that's where I get nervous so trying to
prevent people from getting labeled
um I think is important but I think you
know beyond that we'll have to give up
some things at least it's but especially
at the beginning till we get more
confident yeah makes sense one of the
most asked questions I saw from folks is
just how are you personally navigating
the crisis financially like what are you
buying what are you selling where are
you watching where you think
opportunities on the investment side I
mean I've been lucky like my
entertainment businesses have got
crushed
I mean I'll lose I'm lucid shitload of
money there right just rushed but you
know I was lucky that my core holdings
were Netflix and Amazon and so you know
um that's kind of balancing some things
out so I'm fortunate there but it you
know I still I'm going to catch the
markets going up and there's good
reasons why the markets going up right
for all the good things I that we just
talked about right you know three years
five years from now the market will be
up from where we are today it will be up
you know who knows how much but it will
it'll be better um but I still think we
have a leg down and so I've gone to cash
and
even if not in the public markets if I'm
wrong in the public markets I think
there's going to be companies that need
capital in this in this America 2.0 that
are going to be what we just talked
about right there's gonna be when we
look back in ten years there's gonna be
some amazing companies that were created
and having access to cash or having cash
is gonna give me the opportunity to
invest in them and like I said I'm super
excited about that I don't know who it's
gonna be but if you got it bring it to
me
forget Bitcoin for a second let's just
stick with other non public assets
anything around bold land commodities
anything in there um I think commodities
go up because I think we'll get at least
some modicum of inflation and as
companies to kind of try to protect
their own manufacturing and try to
really bring core core necessities
domestically I think that could push up
the value of commodities I couldn't tell
you which ones to invest in but just
generically and on a macro basis um I'm
not a big gold fan i analogize that more
to Bitcoin and um just because what are
you going to do right we saw it all hit
the fan and there ain't nobody walking
around with gold
there ain't nobody asking for payment in
gold and we're pretty money as fast as
we can and things aren't deflating or
inflating at least not yet
right and so there's I don't see that as
being a solution we saw what happened to
oil right and so manufacturers you know
can come in or the drillers in this case
Saudi Arabia and Russia the leaders can
come in just turn them industry upside
down and the same thing can happen with
gold you know so what about on the real
estate side anything there yeah I mean
I'm looking right I'm trying to be
opportunistic and agile not necessarily
to take advantage of people's misfortune
but um I just think that there'll be a
lot of reformulating because there's so
many there's so many companies that were
leveraged you know so companies went to
go buy land or buildings or shopping
centers whatever it may be and they put
down very little capital and they went
and borrowed more and you know then they
sold that you know and the lenders so
that the tranches and you know there
think you're gonna see some deleveraging
there which creates some opportunities
to buy land but you're not seeing all
those discounts yet except in big dense
cities that have had the but like um
like New York you're starting to see
condos the prices there just drop like
rocks so if you think you want to live
in New York in the future now's the time
to buy you know if you think you want a
house in an area that's been hit hard
you know Detroit or wherever it may be
now's the time to buy so I think in for
personal purposes it's a good time to if
you have cash to buy real estate for
sure NBA obviously is gonna come back at
some point let me say one other things
in terms of investment okay on college
right you gotta rethink where you're
going to school and whether you gonna
borrow money at all and colleges
themselves you got to make sure your
college isn't going to go out of
business because their sources of
revenue and just gone they're gone right
they dried up like that you know a lot
of colleges made their money off of
international students coming in and
paying full-ride in terms of tuition and
room and board they can't get in the
country you know and if they get it in
they might not be able to get out and
they may not have the capital you know
or being able to afford and so you're
gonna see a lot of rejiggering of
universities public and to a lesser
extent you know the Ivy League schools
are gonna be okay because there are
endowments but below that you know
you're gonna see a lot of reformat in a
lot of rethinking and who knows when
students go back and so if your school
was going to have you have was going to
force you to do online learning anyways
why are you gonna pay for a full credit
when you can go into any of the other
online sources we go to Coursera and
learn the same stuff for free and then
try to test down or go to a local
community college and then go test out
or transfer your credits so beware that
college is dirt economics are changing
so dramatically that the world is going
to be different if you're one of those
who wanted to go to that school because
it's got a great football or basketball
team they may not be playing anyways and
it's not going to be as social
fraternities sororities are going to
have to rethink everything dorms you're
going to have to rethink everything and
so we talked about going to
Rena's think about going back to school
it's not just about going to class or
watching class where you gonna live you
know there's just so many elements
involved in college life that are going
to change that party probably the after
some of the entertainment industries one
of the the most negatively impacted
industries is going to be schools
universities and as a potential student
as a current student you need to look at
this as the biggest investment you're
gonna make over the next 10 15 years and
really re-evaluate what your choice is
work
yeah the cent that I saw was the average
calculus one course in America in person
2,500 bucks online $400 reasons to write
it so at the school you want to go to
you can test out go take it on course
there or whatever and just try to test
out you know and then that's the same
with jobs two-man jobs are going to be
completely different what are you gonna
do for your first job you're gonna take
any job because you're not trying to get
a career you're a free agent right and
that free agent you're just gonna pay
your bills you just want to have some
liquidity you want to have some
semblance of normalcy and competence in
your financial future
and then as you learn and look you just
paid for college now you're getting paid
to learn when you get to that first job
even if it's the worst job ever you're
gonna learn what you don't like and then
go from there and you start bouncing
from job to job to job till you get to
one you love where you look you figure
out that there's something in this job
you don't realize you love but now you
love but take your the way you approach
your job life is gonna be completely
different yeah getting paid to loans the
better than paying to learn for sure NBA
when it comes back does the business
model change obviously with fans not
their arena at first and also one of the
questions was uh does this kind of break
the camel's back on the cable providers
who are really holding on to a live
sports as as a differentiator well
couple things there one we come back
without fans and that helps the cable
providers you know because they're our
broadcast partners and when we come back
those first games are going to be
through the roof because we need sports
right we want something to cheer for we
want our team to get fired up about we
want to be communal right we're gonna
maybe we'll have VR headsets on and
we'll be watching the game with you know
50 of our friends and VR who knows but
we
need sports and so I think that will
help and you've seen like shark tank
right Friday nights on ABC
you know our ratings any multi-year eyes
and we're on traditional television um
and so you know we're where there's been
television on dramas or whatever on
traditional cable the ratings are doing
better than they have and the court
cutting has slowed down and so coming
back bringing sports back particularly
with no audience in the arenas I think
the number is going to be huge and I
think that will help them at least in
the short term yeah tell me our debt he
owes you a bonus for getting
advertisements in there for sure two
questions to wrap this up one obviously
you've got a position on Bitcoin I
actually think it's a pretty valid
concern like you're gonna take the other
side or the bearer side the argument you
make I think is the perfect argument
what would have to happen for you to
change your mind have to be so easy to
use it's a no-brainer it has to be
completely friction free and
understandable by everybody first and
then then and then you can say it's an
alternative to gold as a store of value
but in terms of being a way to um
transact you know whether it's just
transfers of funds or whatever you've
got to be able to spend it you know cuz
right now you still have to convert it
for anything that you want and as long
as you have to convert it you're still
dependent on fiha no matter what you say
right and I can trade bananas easier as
a commodity that I can trade Bitcoin
right and I can still eat that banana
before it goes bad and get all my
potassium for my workout you know I
can't I you know I can't even you know
with gold Alicia gold cause right or I
can point I can use your gold bar as
furniture you know but with Bitcoin it's
virtual and you know that's the beauty
and that's its problem and so one you're
gonna have to make it friction free so
grandma can do it because now the fact
that we're arguing so much about it and
you have so many stands about Bitcoin or
you know for Bitcoin that just proves
the point you know that it's difficult
and to you can't spend it on anything
you know I think we've spent we put it
up for the Mavs we did it originally
four years ago and no one bought
anything now we're taking Bitcoin
go buy everything a Bitcoin I'm fine
with that right I think we've brought in
$130 and that's all the Bitcoin that I
own right now yeah yeah I think part of
it too is user experience nothing has to
improve the big question is is this
email you know 25 years ago and it does
improve or it doesn't that's opportunity
and risk that people take right yeah
plus you know there's so many
peculiarities to Bitcoin right the
having right you know the mining in that
you know the fact that blockchain is a
great opportunity but in reality we
haven't seen blockchain applications
really take off you know and there's
uncertainty with all the different types
of Kryptos you know and the arguments
between all the different types of
Kryptos you know these are things that
just you know create more and more
confusion and diminish the confidence
and so yeah I get all the arguments I've
seen all the charts right I understand
that you know the profit potential
problems with fiat but you know -
bitcoins potential benefit if everything
goes into the [ __ ] because we're
prettying so much money and there's
global implications Bitcoin has got
something to deal with and something to
say and if we don't Bitcoin again
nothing I actually appreciate your
detractors because they're usually
pretty rational right so I tend to agree
it I think it's that the right position
to take on the other side last question
for you the big one in the room what
would it take for you to run for
president in 2020 and if not then 2020
for my family saying yes otherwise I
would have already done it
and you know I haven't ruled it out cuz
everybody asked me and it's like well
why don't you just say yes or no because
so much crazy [ __ ] is happening you know
wrong person gets sick right everything
changes you know we don't but people are
afraid to go out or the economy gets
worse everything changes you know and I
think what's really missing is no one
understands technology and technology
out of the candidates and even our
senior politicians and you know our most
powerful powerful politicians they don't
get tech at all and yet tech is going to
drive America 2.0 more than anything we
could ever wise do you know whether it's
robotics AI precision medicine all these
things are going to be the foundation to
our economy going forward and nobody
who's running and nobody who's behind
those people who running or in positions
of power get any of that and that's the
real problem part of I think what's
really interesting is the one thing that
Donald Trump definitely did in his
presidential run was he kind of changed
the rules of the game right certain
things that were taboo before now are
cool you see that with the Andrew yang
tight campaign you see with Mike
Bloomberg and all the memes and just a
lot of things have changed I guess
what's the PlayBook that you pull out
it's like I say for 2020 and you got a
couple of months and what do you do to
even have a shot I mean I talk about
American 2.0 I talk about the fact that
I hate both parties to talk about the
fact that literally that I would I would
try to get rid of both parties they
serve no purpose I talk about the fact
that you know Supreme Court I would
balance it I would make sure that
there's a Republican and independent a
Democrat repeat right that when it comes
to appointing people for positions I
don't care what their political
affiliation is I'd appoint the best
person you know and most likely it turns
into a balance again with independents
those are the types of things where
people just say you know what just put
the best person in I don't care if
you're a Republican or Democrat I'm
happy to work with you you know
Speaker of the House I wouldn't put a
politician in there you know you don't
have to be an elected official to be the
Speaker of the House I would go out
there and find somebody from the outside
who can add some balance you know
there's just so many different things
that that just reach wreck that allow me
to reject traditional politics that
nobody who's a politician is able to do
and so I think that's what creates a lot
of opportunity for me I got to speak for
a lot of people if you went in and said
our whole our whole mission here is to
get rid of the politicians and get you
know business leaders and entrepreneurs
in here I think you'd have a pretty big
following and not just entrepreneurs
right I mean look there's people who
understand government who aren't
politicians right the fact that you have
there's the come an organization that
give a lot of money to a called
competitive democracy org and their
whole mission in life is to help
independents get on balance because the
Republicans and Democrats you everything
possible to keep nan Republic or
Democratic candidates off the ballot so
we don't get the best candidates and so
those are the types of things that if I
walked in I would say all that shit's
out the door right
politics are gone right it's about doing
what's right for the American people
that's that would be me right America
2.0 from a political and an economic and
technological perspective where we put
people first you jack up the minimum
wage if a company has people that are on
public assistance you find out why and
you solve that problem there's just a
lot of things where we can put people
first and really propel this country to
do better things when we get on the
other side of this yeah it'd be hell of
a story to go if it's out my head but
listen to be hell of a story to go from
sleeping on the floor in the apartment
to dancing naked being a billionaire and
eventually the Oval Office
give you all the credit do that
accelerated me man that's my launching
pad right all right listen mark I really
appreciate it
just keep doing you man it we're all all
cheer John and we're enjoying it so
thanks so much for doing this
I appreciate thanks for having me on